[Music]  yeah i'm really sincerely enjoying the  olympics one of my favorite things about  watching them is all the super  slow-motion video they use for the  instant replays  just love that the super slow-mo with  majestic music added makes me it just  makes the athletes look so incredibly  cool  and that got us thinking why can't we  get in on that  so i looked into it i found out you can  rent one of those olympic super  slow-motion cameras so we got one  and just today we recorded some of our  own  great moments  take a look  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  ah  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  by the way ladies that's my oh face  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Laughter]